[Music]
on the on this carpet
it's like when I auditioned it's like
this is what it's worth I just looked
down as you lecie Vanessa Hudgens you
know just talking
oh yeah life is great just casually just
you know flipping out it's bebe Rexha
she just asked if she could write a song
for you grace Vander Waal and bebe Rexha
sharing a moment at Sunday's Teen Choice
Awards bebe also got candid about
working with Louie Tomlinson performing
tonight with mr. Louie how's that going
to be amazing I remember coming to the
Teen Choice Awards and literally filling
in the seats and to kinda like you know
now I'm here and I wouldn't choose
anybody else
he's been so awesome to work with and
sometimes you get scared in the music
business with who you're gonna work with
he's like the coolest Chile's guy up
it's interesting to hear that he's like
surprisingly chill anything else that
you were surprised about you know what
like yes that Matt is I know that's like
guy does the main thing but you know you
expect one direction it's like you
expect them to be like you know they're
superstars like I wanted to order sushi
at the video shoot and he was like sushi
he's like love we don't have that here
we have Stu and like hit like meat and
rice I'm like uggs were in his staff in
his hometown and I was like that's very
la I mean I feel so embarrassed
but uh yeah he's like even dresses so
chill I'm like I'm wearing heels and
stuff and he's like wearing tracksuit he
doesn't care